knights and questing name a more iconic
duo
whenever you think of the medieval age
it's a partnership that often springs to
mind
in which knights would undertake daring
quests to save a damsel retrieve a holy
artifact or capture a castle
but did this sort of thing actually
happen did medieval knights really go
questing
so the answer for the most part is no
sorry the notion of a knight wandering
into a tavern and getting a quest or his
king asking him to find a holy relic
just wasn't a thing
we'll focus on the late medieval period
since this was peak chivalry
most knights were of middling rank who
served a local lord and they spent most
of their time
administering their own lands making
sure your peasants paid you you
fulfilled your obligations to your lord
and maintaining law and order was a
full-time job
which as you'll note isn't questing
knights were also responsible for some
military duties like providing levies
and they themselves were expected to
stay in top form which sometimes
included traveling to tournaments
so the knights that administered land
often had several sons and only one of
them was going to inherit it all
so what about the rest well they mostly
caused trouble
some though would stay in their family
territories and were responsible for
things like collecting tolls
you see traveling across medieval europe
could be dangerous and it's often
because of these tolls
knights and lords would demand payment
for safe passage through their lands and
if you couldn't pay you'd be forced out
and if you didn't pay but sort of looked
like you could you were liable for being
ransomed
often these wayward sons and their
friends would join mercenary bands to
fight all over europe and often on
behalf of the lord they would raid their
neighbours
and all of this was illegal and so many
young knights and even high-ranking
noblemen were imprisoned and punished
for doing it
in fact 15th century france and the holy
roman empire had a real problem with
robber knights
who as the name suggests were knights
who just went around and robbed people
these were particularly bad during
periods of national instability
if central authority was diminished
knights would just go to town
and then robert blind so was there
anything similar to our idea of
requesting night
the only other real example of questing
in the traditional spiritual sense of
accomplishing a great feat
is the crusades knights and lords of all
inheritances would answer the pope's
call and travel to the holy land to do
their christian duty and retake some
cities and safeguards and artifacts
the call to crusade was one of the
spiritual quest as well as one for luton
prestige
but barring that the idea of a knight or
a small group of adventurers setting out
on a quest for an item or something
along those lines
just didn't happen except in literature
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly money maker the pastry section
marvin cassow rob waterhouse danny
maloney
moe aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley marcus asner jerry lamdin
gustav swan rasheed ali
colin carson copper tone izzy david
silverman spinning three plates
winston k wood spencer lightfoot maggie
paxkowski
matthew shipley anthony beckett
fortunate calf robert wetzel lexi
schwinn and skye chappelle